paiement le verdict est tombé hier soir
réclusion à perpétuité pour l'assassin
de monsieur chapour bakhtiar le dernier
premier ministre du chah d'iran dix ans
de réclusion pour son principal complice
et l'acquittement pour un troisième main
intermédiaires employés du ministère des
affaires étrangères iranien sur qui
pesait de sérieux soupçons mais pas de
preuves ce qui n'est pas l'avis de la
famille de monsieur bakhtiar en tout cas
le gouvernement iranien lui a fait
savoir à fait connaître par dont sa
satisfaction à la suite de ce jugement
qui selon le gouvernement iranien donc
prouve que l'iran n'était pas impliqué
directement dans cette affaire dominique
verdeilhan eric mes explications libre
mais expulsé acquitté par la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris à 20 heures
hier soir une heure plus tard zonal
sarhadi est prié par le ministère de
l'intérieur de quitter la france au plus
vite et en iran
je pense qu'il dit de retourner en iran
et par d'autres et dont il ne sait pas
encore mais certainement je pense qu'il
souhaite retourner en iran ce matin ses
avocats laissé entendre que sarah 10
pourrait rejoindre son pays avant la fin
de la semaine des avocats qui ne
s'explique pas l'arrêté d'expulsion
la justice vient dinos d'innocenter un
homme vient de juger que cet homme est
innocent est-ce que vous ne trouverez
pas inadmissible que le pouvoir exécutif
haye contre la décision le pouvoir
judiciaire et prennent contrôle une
mesure qui ne se justifie pas
la veuve de chapour bakhtiar elle ne
s'explique pas l'équipement du troisième
vol bien sûr que vous allez voir
tehran ravi vous allez voir que ce soir
à l'ambassade de la république islamique
on va
excuser
on va rire à la barbe de la justice
française c'est tout ce que je sois en
iran n'est pas condamnée et seuls les
débats ont permis d'être le mettre en
cause la responsabilité de l'iran mais
la décision est là et ça on ne peux pas
la contester
après cet acquittement la famille de
chapour bakhtiar espère simplement ne
pas revivre l'épisode de lagrasse danis
nakache en 90